welcome to this video playing Hestia
best horses are best as I learned as
this meaning there a name nope let's got
a horse picture and now um okay yep and
what's this costa rica thailand oh man
the costa rica's the same colors okay
let's see the the room at this line yeah
this is surprisingly popular and the
reason is people tend to forget what to
play like I'm like I'm doing now it
really isn't that great but how exactly
what's the theory here 36 PP 596 be far
these are so lab5 be 5i d6 Bishop d5 is
also a line it's not particularly good
but then easily forget it castles and f4
this Bishop g4 one yeah I am but how to
proceed from here yeah white has given
up the bishop pal and he has no
particular compensation for it sometimes
he can get two piece here every piece
3596 i take and then d 5 is freed yeah
maybe maybe just just play here keep it
simple and before you can put anything
on c6 he needs to yeah play something
like that first not sure that this is so
desirable
yeah now i have a bishop f6 coming and
the b6 night is always taking a look at
the d5 pawn some yeah before was
probably probably a threat
yeah comfortable position but how to
play maybe just to create take it and
keep it simple Joe age 6 I can do this
as well 333 hmm yeah that's not doing
very much really I can take Queen f8 and
rook e8 maybe check trading looks this
painting probably just beneficial for me
I'm not sure what this is doing maybe 94
but I can take you five sorry yeah yeah
I can have everything else fails I can
take him take c3 apply 95 I did some
it's not very ambitious is it 94 may be
coming I can also take here and take you
five what is the point you will play 97
not okay let's just do this symbol in
simple plain I actually forgot about
that I had seen it before but then
forgot about it
mm yeah but slightly uncomfortable this
Bishop that I need to move it
kim beom the passive move didn't look
right we should be 8 or something but
this looks a bit strange sort of here
chattering wrapped into its position but
yeah there was also fif p.m. as a threat
okay f5 now looks weakening but probably
probably still okay
that's a tricky position I mean with the
two bishops I should be okay but my king
fields week there are ideas I don't know
there might be ideas i don't i don't see
anything right for him but this does not
necessarily mean there isn't something
okay guys now i can just take here right
or take here first and take on d5 I can
I can do this first yeah and queen takes
I take on d5 isn't this just winning
winning material here like a whole piece
mighty fine how is he not losing a PCM
white resigned yeah he isn't jam very
tricky position I mean certainly I
should be ok but I shouldn't also i
shouldn't do it quickly I think here I
have a good coordination Bishop on f6 is
good the d7 Bishop is serving its
purpose and the night on b6 always a
text e5 ok this is a normal move Queen
d3j and I don't know but this this is
this is probably okay I mean shouldn't
shouldn't be bad ok 926 and no I went
through key aide yeah yeah this is in
fact a big mistake according to the
computer because of Bishop e2 a.m. yeah
well I've found the move because there
isn't anything better I mean Bishop
Bishop Becca cannot be the solution so
it should be 2m attacking a 3 and
threatening f5 this is a serious double
threat
computer wants to go rugby one giving up
the apron now maybe on be 4f night c4 I
thought computer wants to go f5 is this
not good that's 92 ok ok but f5 ok this
was lucky I was thinking that 94 always
would be would be ok I can also take
here first the Sun this is also possible
but ok now you should be 3m so again
problematic ok but this is probably not
good right you know ffff 5 preserves a
pretty clash the computer actually
prefers to take on a three but this is
too cold blooded for me hmm get here
Bishop see three wins wins the house
yeah just lose a certain material yeah
surprisingly quicker your complete again
quick defeat for white him yeah this is
this line with with default it is
surprisingly popular in blitz it's
really totally unpromising but it can
easily happen that black forgets as them
your theory and gets in trouble or uses
lots of time around here I think black
is really very comfortable should you
should be at least equal with the with
the two bishops white has to space
everything's great ok but long-term you
really have very little to show ok hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching